welcome to this video pommel pill again
played him just before until we get some
Owens defends here where black is
basically giving Y to the center now
thats it's a quite nice position nothing
spectacular but certainly certainly
convenient for white to play I put the
night on g3 I thought that he should
prevent this he didn't do it and night
now only has d5 and I don't know here I
can take actually and isn't this this
close to working the Greek gift I think
it's dying check everything's set set in
a way that it should work age 7 and f7
is some pre and a half g three the night
on g3 is also a good attacking piece
yeah it's here's a case where 94 is
important here or is there something
better even know this is good
now d6f six is the the big the big
problem for black and Queenie seven is
made into so he's going to going to lose
some some stuff now I mean like like
enough to resign I don't see him move
him check holy holy moly okay yeah okay
he wants to go queen age six after that
I seem hmm
yeah that's a way to continue really
it's quite funny but that's a way to
continue I cannot take on f7 Queen age
six now already queued so if i take hmm
hmm take okay it's a good position but
it's not winning amazing maybe this was
really defending I overlooked something
um ok here lost 96cm ok probably he
couldn't defend it anyway it's not it's
not that the terrible I'm cookie for
every rookie for h4 or g4 try to use the
temporary misplacement of black's pieces
with the tempo and then Knight to e5
checking f7 and centralizing the night
and does he have something else than age
5 nope so 90 m
very peculiar position it's certainly
good for widen if you give it to a
computer that's still quite quite weird
weird to play
okay maybe I should have taken with the
rook actually just keeping control okay
this one's does he want to go to c 6 i'm
going to take on f7 anyway I guess
oh ok
don't no way he's going with this night
Becky ow Bishop check
it is just a check here hmm let's just
go back here controlling g6 and
coordinating a bit better okay maybe I
can take him getting the pawn on getting
down to the seventh rank one good news
is that is also taking his time it's not
he's not dashing out moves all the time
we are taking Knight takes rook c7 and
if he takes with the keynotes half 97
that's very not that's not a very M nice
position to play okay i'm jang going for
that trying to to keep it simple
I just saw that it's not so easy maybe I
should just save this exchange exchange
this
yeah it just keeps good control
maybe that wasn't oh no is giving Jess
this exchange I'm going to take this
black resign yeah I probably didn't
really finish him off in the best
possible way but let's let's go back to
this that was really funny we have the
Greek gift so I'm going to chime and now
after this so it's better to check first
and then play 94 yeah this is this a
stronger Jack yeah I really didn't see
Bishop h2 this is this is stronger he
only has this month now 96 check and
then we have a clearly improved version
of the game with f7 hanging he ate
hanging and b7 hang and white is a pawn
up which pounds up to a complete win and
here here this is this funky defense
amazing wait did have I can take with
the queen of course oh how blind can you
be of course I can take with the Queen
here why didn't I look at that yeah when
I can I can go here that sets a much
stronger there's still this idea and of
course there are many discoveries
threatened like this this is much
stronger here it's it sets a bit better
for white but it's nothing nothing
totally convincing no but this is a
series of good moose work t4 were
stronger though I just this have played
far too quickly through this automatic
recapture but this is stronger the rook
is back into play and I can play c4 to
get away the strong night is the ice
lated porn is also a point but it's
mostly that the rook and in connection
with c4 helps me to drive away a snide
that's very much better for wider yeah
and here I really I really allowed some
things in check check I can play 96 see
why don't I do that strange sometimes a
very cute move here the computer gives
rook f4 that's very nice that's very
nice this is leading to made check
checkmate very nice and of course yeah
what what should like do with if he does
something like that check is this movie
okay so this was much stronger than than
my continuation here is his playing
again not losing but Rock d8 London it
okay was down almost a minute so it
would have been very difficult in any
case okay thanks for watching